considera las funciones efe junto con
las gráficas que se muestran a
continuación y aquí nos dan justo las
gráficas de gx y de fx que es la azul
sige mayúscula de x es g compuesta con
fx cuál es el valor de g prima g
mayúscula que mayúscula prima de 2.5 muy
bien entonces realmente este es un
problema muy interesante porque no nos
dan la definición explícita de quién es
efe y quién es que simplemente nos dan
la gráfica de las funciones muy bien
entonces a partir de esta información lo
que nosotros tenemos que obtener es la
derivada de la composición evaluada en
2.5 y que sería bueno ir marcando que
aquí está el 2.5 muy bien entonces vamos
a ver qué es lo que podemos hacer
voy a reescribir lo que tenemos que de x
x será igual voy a hacerlo con otro
color que evaluada la g minúscula
evaluada en fx
muy bien esto es lo que tenemos así que
si nosotros queremos encontrar la
derivada de g mayúscula entonces tenemos
que derivar de ambos lados de esta
igualdad verdad entonces derivamos la g
mayúscula y esto debe ser igual a la
derivada de g seguida de f muy bien
entonces qué es lo que vamos a tener que
usar para calcular esto pues necesitamos
usar la regla de la cadena y que nos
dice la regla de la cadena que esta
composición es simplemente digamos la
derivada de g respecto de fx que lo
podemos escribir como g prima evaluada
en fx
en fx por la derivada de lo de adentro
que es la derivada de f muy bien
entonces con esto ya podemos seguir ir
tratando de encontrar quién es la
derivada de g mayúscula evaluada en 2.5
y vamos a intentar hacerlo vamos no sé
por ejemplo si pongo 2.5 con otro color
para no perdernos tenemos la derivada de
g mayúscula en 2.5 esto será igual a la
derivada de g minúscula evaluada ahora
en f pero en evaluada en 2.5 en 2.5 por
la derivada de f en 2.5 de hecho lo está
haciendo con otro color verdad en 2.5 y
aquí evaluado en 2.5 que es el punto que
marcamos al inicio del vídeo muy bien
entonces vamos a tener que calcular toda
esta información quién es
y evaluada en 2.5 déjenme ponerlo así
efe evaluado en 2.5 y para eso tenemos
que irnos a la gráfica porque f evaluada
en 2.5 está justamente aquí que es 1
déjenme ponerlo con con el color que ya
teníamos
ahí está entonces efe evaluada en 2.5
vale 1 esto es igual a 1 muy bien quien
sería ahora f prima la derivada de f
evaluada en 2.5 evaluado en 2.5 y para
eso simplemente nos fijamos que la recta
tangente a la gráfica pues es ella misma
porque ésta es una recta así que tenemos
que ver por cada cuantos que avanzamos
en la dirección que avanzamos en la
dirección x digamos m ver aquí teníamos
este punto y tomaré este x que está
justo en una coordenada 42 que es
bastante agradable entonces fíjense que
por cada tres cuadritos que yo avanzo
hacia la derecha subo dos cuadritos en
la dirección vertical entonces si
recordamos la definición de pendiente es
el avance en y dividido entre el avance
en x entonces aquí tenemos
y aquí tenemos tres por supuesto si lo
viéramos en la escala normal aquí
tendríamos una verdad avanzamos de 1 a 2
y aquí avanzamos 1.5 pero eso es lo
mismo que 1 entre 1.5 si multiplicamos
por 2 tanto arriba como abajo esto es 2
sobre 3 que justamente es 2 entre 3 así
que podemos hacerlo simplemente de
fijarnos en los cuadritos así que esto
es dos tercios muy bien entonces fíjense
que necesitamos la derivada de g
evaluada en f evaluada en 2.5 que es 1
entonces necesitamos calcular que prima
evaluado en uno que prima evaluado en
uno y es lo que necesitamos cuanto vale
esto bueno nos vamos a la gráfica de g y
vemos cuánto valen 1 aquí está en 1
cuánto avanzamos pues si por ejemplo
avanzamos 1 a la derecha y subimos 2
otro punto de la gráfica verdad entonces
avanzamos 1 y subimos 2 por lo tanto la
pendiente en 1 es 2 entre 1 que es 2 es
2 muy bien así que ya tenemos toda la
información necesaria para resolver el
problema porque entonces que prima
evaluada en en 2.5 evaluamos en 2.5 es
igual es igual
tenemos que prima evaluado en f de 2.5
que es g prima de 1 y eso es 2 esto esto
de aquí vale 2 y la derivada de f en 2.5
es dos tercios
así que multiplicamos por dos tercios y
esto simplemente nos da cuatro tercios y
ya tenemos resuelto este problema que a
mí me parece que fue un problema muy
bonito
no teníamos la definición de estas
funciones efe
y sin embargo pudimos llevar llegar
perdón al resultado con solo información
visual espero les haya gustado